So the first thing you need to do in
order to reach your potential or do what
you really meant to do is understand
your own strengths and weaknesses.
And it turns out that most people I
talked to do not know their strengths
and weaknesses.
They may be,
can take a stab at their strengths,
but they have a tough time writing down
their weaknesses.
The trap people fall in often is they
say,
I'm in a class of 50 other people,
or I'm in a job with 20 other peers and
ought to be able to be good at
everything they're good at if they're
good at something that I want to be good
at.
And the reality is every,
every person is good at certain things
to a certain degree and not as good at
others.
The trick is to figure out your
strengths and weaknesses and what the
things are you need to improve on.
You have to assess them versus a
specific job.
If I want to be a newspaper reporter,
there are certain sets of strengths and
weaknesses I need.
If I want to be an investment banker,
it's a different set of I want to be a
college professor.
It's another set.
So you need to understand your own
strengths and weaknesses and then
calibrate it to what you need to do very
well to be outstanding in that job.
Figuring out your strengths and
weaknesses probably is not something you
can do all by yourself.
You need to get advice and observations
from people who watch you,
who see you in action and can point out
to you what you're good at and what
you're not good at.
And the reason it helps to get advice
from others is we all have blind spots.
Problem is it has to be skill based.
It can't be a morphis,
it can't be generalized needs to be
based on skills that are relevant to
whatever task you're doing.
And then ideally a coach would give you
some advice on techniques for improving
the skills you need to be open to
hearing things that you don't want to
hear and you need to not send off a vibe
that you don't want to hear.
Feedback.
The mistakes people make as they either
don't understand their own strengths and
weaknesses,
they're not willing to get advice from
others to get feedback on what they're
really good at and they don't calibrate
it against a job.
What I'm trying to encourage people to
do is do this systematically because
your strengths and your weaknesses are
really the building blocks of what,
whatever,
whatever you're going to try to do.